and since we are already getting a light
start on this my apologies uh I suggest
we uh bang the gavel and get started
right away
and we're here today to hear testimony
from at least
three uh people who sign up in advance
testim is always open to others if you
would like to make a a pink slip and
bring it up to here we can make sure
that we get your testimony as
well and
uh without further Ado Let's us get
started um like to hear
from
Clark first pardon
me and if you could push the red button
on your microphone once you get settled
and then State your complete name and uh
title for the record thank
you
for the record my name is Clark
Corson uh I am a co-founder with Carol
Foss who sits to my immediate right of a
New Hampshire nonprofit called
collaborative Solid Waste
strategies and we are focused
on education advocacy and Innovation
meaning looking outside the box to find
altern ways to landfills and
incineration Plastics is a vital
component of
trash people who speak behind me today
will are much more qualified to address
the particulars and the percentages of
trash and so forth Carol can I see just
that thanks I forgot
this I've provided written testimony I'm
not going to take up a lot of your time
because
others will more specifically address
the nuances of what I'm aiming at
but extended producer
responsibility in the big scheme of
things is a relatively New Concept it
shifts the
burden from the consumer to the
manufacturer which is what Europe has
done for five years and Canada just
passed about three weeks
ago there are 23 bills presently pending
in our five contiguous not contiguous
our
five New England states that comprise
New England 23 bills presently being
considered eight of those bills are
seriously being considered and will'll
probably get past this year two in
Connecticut three in Massachusetts one
in Vermont and I think one in
main I don't I hope from the bottom of
my heart
that this committee at least allows the
full lower chamber to have a look at the
nuances and the goodness and the
demerits of what the proposed Bill may
offer I think the Full House deserves to
hear and I think you as a
committee eyeball to eyeball have an
obligation to let them debate it I
understand that if the four-person
committee it is split down the middle in
terms of whether you want to pass it
over there it bothers me quite frankly
that of a 400 person house it comes down
to four people making that decision
irrespective of how you come down on
it this is a matter of serious it can't
be any more
serious I have testified numerous times
on setbacks from standing bodies of
water of landfill and so
forth I will just share this with you
briefly when I started lobbying here in
1971 I was the executive director and
lobbyist for the beer industry in New
Hampshire I fought my living tail off to
defeat bottle
bills but lots of things happen in a
half a
century and I'm here today to tell you
that New Hampshire is way behind the
eightball in terms of seriously
addressing the issue of solid waste the
climate leachates
soil carbon Footprints these are all new
terms that weren't around 50 years ago
50 years ago it was about
litter Elma Johnson was a representative
in charge of the this the inar
committee and he was a farmer and said
that his milk was tasting tiny because
the cows were eating so many aluminum
cans in those days actually there were
steel cans but then it became solid
waste not l so much but solid waste
recycling
Redemption today you have be you you
have this plastic Council in New
Hampshire who cares enough about
sustainable Solid Waste Management to to
have invested their time effort and
research and I ask you to at least let
the Full House consider the merits of
their
arguments there are two points there are
two points I've been asked to make I'm
rambling so my my mother is telling me
what I should do here I'm going to read
these uh a can and this is my testimony
a Canadian study compared prices of
common consumer produ products at
retailers in paired cities with and
without
e in eastern central and western Canada
and found no correlation between product
prices and the presence or absence of
epr that is cited as a reference in my
testimony a Columbia University study
Bose 2022 estimated the impact of Epi
regulation on prices of packaged
consumer goods based on food price
elasticities and USD
estimates of packaging
costs this study conclude concluded that
packaging costs constituted
approximately 2.3% of food expenditures
and estimated that food prices would
increase less than 1% of the
EP regulations were implemented now I
just want to say one thing about that
that statement in and by
itself if it does cost 1% so
what
1% so
what what does it cost to handle solid
waste our state is so far behind our
sister States particularly Vermont
Maine as it applies to things such as
this G jahen tried to get a solid waste
master plan
passed in
2002 just this past October Mike nor is
here I think he'll testify to this did
the state finally through the
legislature enact a solid waste master
plan maybe that's why 50 plus perent of
the trash going into New Hampshire
landfills comes from
Massachusetts Vermont insists that it be
sanitized it doesn't allow it Maine
doesn't allow it New Hampshire allows it
because we did not be proactive we sat
back and let we didn't take I guess we
didn't just take it seriously
enough I hope that you take Plastics
more seriously because this is a time to
do it on this bright October morning you
can make a difference second
Point Epi programs cost to producers are
extremely low the Natural Resources
Council of Maine used the fee schedule
for for
Quebec Quebec's uh Epi program it
measured weights of 14 different
packaging materials to calculate
stewardship fees per package got right
down in the
weeds these fees range from
0. 6 to
0032 for paper and
cardboard and
001 to 013 for various
Plastics so you can you can argue about
the dimensions of cost until the cows
come
home I don't know how relevant that is
in the big scheme of things when New
Hampshire has has become the trash dump
for other New England
states so I'll simply leave you with the
with the the thought
that
the ball is in your
hands as a courtesy to the balance of
the members in the house I hope you will
allow them to debate the
issue before New Hampshire falls even
further
behind whether it be the solid waste
master plan whether it be the fact that
our landfills are now accepting
Massachusetts trash main trash Vermont
trash and if the Bethlehem project goes
through Northern New York trash as well
that's not the issue here today the
issue is what component of solid waste
can this committee address
today thank
you thank you and I'd ask committee if
there are
questions okay I would like to ask a
couple questions if I may try to answer
them I'm not sure I know we all try but
uh this is education very much for us so
you said there's 23 bills uh considered
um in in our New England region uh many
uh quite a few uh will may see the light
of day this coming within the air do you
see other states passing these type of
this type of
legislation um does that have a
detrimental effect on um what we're
receiving in New Hampshire
potentially I mean uh as far as our
waste flow is concerned I'm not sure I
understand the question with other
states passing epr legislation can I
have I'm by all means by all means yes a
little bit hard of hearing too so oh no
no yes by all means and please uh
introduce yourself and
then Carol fos um executive director of
collaborative Solid Waste strategies yes
thank you and thank you again for both
appearing um my concern is if we're the
last state to pass epr legislation that
will make us more vulnerable to uh what
waste flow they're shipping in from
other states where if we get ahead of
the game by passing EPA epr sooner we
will have some protection in managing
that waste flow is that
reasonable I think if other
states if other states adopt
eprs then I would think that the that
those States people in those States
transfer stations in those States would
be
recycling the materials that have
eprs so if it's mattresses if it's
batteries if
it's used paint
whatever people are going to I mean
individuals from other states are not
personally bringing their trash to New
Hampshire it's going to a transfer
station and it's those transfer stations
that are Contracting with somebody to
move that waste from the transfer
station to wherever to a landfill to an
incinerator to New Hampshire to to
whatever so if those land if those
transfers if those states have an epr
law then those transfer stations are
going to be the ones kind of
managing where those materials go so
they will not be coming to New
Hampshire thank you one further
question I'll try to be a little more
succinct you were talking about the 1%
cost which I consider to be quite light
uh but could that 1% cost even be offset
by reduction in potential reduction in
Municipal Taxes I'll answer that
one I can assure you and I don't think
there would be much argument from either
side that manufacturers have already
built into their cost of doing business
the
anticipation of Epi regulation in our
state and I can tell you that when the
bottle bills were passed in Maine
Vermont Massachusetts and
Connecticut the cost of relabeling
containers was built in New Hampshire of
course with no sense of broad-based
Taxation fully jumped on that to take
advantage of out of state sales so to
Carol's point would more be coming to
New Hampshire if New Hampshire did not
adopt that I don't know the answer to
that I would think that manufacturers
would have to have I can't believe that
they would have 13 states here four
states there in the midwest doing one
thing and other states not doing another
that's how I would have answered your
first question but they build into the
cost of doing business and that's why I
I tend to minimize the fact that a one
tenth of 1% if that's the cost to a
consumer it is going to be there
regardless thank you any further
questions I thank you both
next I would like to hear like to hear
from Cynthia
Walter just have to set
up and we have done this before our last
on one of our prior committees where we
have one screen to share would anybody
be opposed if I invited those who would
like to
sit and observe the screen to come
forward that's fine with that well if
you'd like to come and so I can see the
screen as we did last time if you were
here it give us a quum yeah we have a
quorum
actually
is it showing up yet think I need to
wake it
up well we may not have a show oh here
it comes there you
go
it's working it's working yeah finally
did woke
up thank you
John this takes a minute to open these
things up sometimes and have them
respond to you take all the time you eat
no problem
on
it's not giving me that option
huh
slideshow ah from beginning it's just
not giving me that that
option
huh um here let me just let me just open
up another another version of this my
computer's just mocking out on me sorry
about that I had it all all set up
here it just screen yeah it's uh um it
wouldn't give me full screen my I think
I just need to pull it up in a different
tech window or something I'll just I'll
just pull it up out of my out of my
files um here's the PDF
PowerPoint and this should sorry about
the wait so I'm Cynthia Walter I'm the
uh co-director of the uh um no Dover New
Hampshire do plastic reduction group in
Dover New Hampshire and my screen is
just really knocked out here
Healy yeah I don't know where I can try
yeah can you give me your hand here um
right so I do have I will be able to
email my um testim testimony to you and
I do have the uh PowerPoint slides that
I have packets for you folks to take
home and maybe one to send to the to the
one member of the four person committee
who's not here today so we'll have those
ready for you in just a second we'll
have the just close these out yeah thank
you CH oh you're welcome see if it's
getting
working so I again I thank you for your
effort in working on this difficult
problem um I'm a scientist um retired
after a 35 year career in teaching and
research with a focus on pollution
problems and solutions excuse
responsibility laws excuse me I'm going
to ask you to turn that microphone more
towards yourself if you mind I'm sorry
yes so I'm sorry so I'm a scientist
retired after a 35y year career in
teaching and research with a focus on
pollution problems and solutions
extended producer responsibility laws
provide important opportunities to
develop solutions to our expanding
problems of waste and exposures to
toxins um if you have any questions I'm
available the exposure to toxins is the
focus of my talk
today so that's the one yes exactly so
um I me I'll just stay standing um so we
have savings that we will have from
safer
packaging and I want to show you how we
can limit toxics in New Hampshire laws
there'll be more market share um savings
throughout the packaging lifetime more
confident consumers and improved company
health because they things will be safer
for the products themselves and
improvements in personal health because
they'll be safer for your
family so let's start at the beginning
what do we have here well let's go
through a few problems and then some
lose some solutions so problem number
one some packaging contains toxins
banned in 19 States and all of Europe so
we already have in New Hampshire
Plastics liner in coffee cups that
contains pasas that you can see this
plastic uh melt melted liner has then um
um is something that we're drinking
liquid out of form liquid um not a good
idea so also containers now we know can
leech harmful chemicals exceeding the
safe limits for baby foods so we have
those in our stores our parents are
buying these things for the little tiny
babies we have toxic Metals in packaging
spread spreading into pars made from
recycling now I'm aware that we have a
1996 law in New Hampshire we were very
forward thinking in
'96 to have a law that bans some metals
in some kinds of sum packaging so we
have a start at that already and no one
probably noticed too much about the
problems in 1996 associated with the
cost issues they simply said having
metals are toxic we have to take them
out of our packaging we have to take
them out of our exposures that's the
more important thing to focus on and we
did it in 1996 but we stopped with just
a few of those things for a few
situations associated with products and
packaging epr now can make that be
stronger so the second problem um EP
each business is now
paying um to to spend money on handling
problem chemicals at every step in the
supply chain so they're already paying
for this and with
epr across New Hampshire and across
other states as well this actually
streamlines business operations and
reduces much of their paperwork and
worker
exposures problem three toxics
contaminate products people in the
environment and recycling to begin the
products the products contain right now
if you look around you over 10,000
different additives 4,000 of which have
not been studied but for those that have
been studied over a thousand showed up
to be of High Health concern they're in
the things we have around us now um the
known impacts from these and again this
is just a I didn't cherry pick the data
and the impacts I'm citing these are
cited again and again
infertility sperm count in the United
States and other developed countries has
declined by over half these things are
called the diseases of the developed
world and infertility is a major problem
impaired nervous systems we're seeing
more and more people with learning
disabilities coming along and it's a
it's a you know tragedy um and maybe an
unnecessary tragedy to happen cancer
many cancers are triggered by chemical
additives and now cancer is among the
top cause of death in children for among
for
disease so that's problem 3A problem 3B
the toxins keep going again they
contaminate the food in our Plastics
especially recycled Plastics um and even
the baby food like I cited before toxics
contaminate the food chain so that when
people come to New Hampshire for our
wonderful fishing and our wonderful
wildlife and so forth and they eat those
fish they eat the wildlife we want to
make sure that those things are sa those
animals and are safe for them for people
to eat toxics contaminate our leech fill
land our landfill leech Ates so we hope
that our landfills don't leak but we all
know first of all the leech a that we do
collect from landfills has to be the
treated for these accelerated very
difficult to handle toxics when we put
more toxics into the landfill the leech
at toxics go up the landfill right near
my house TurnKey landfill seven of the
10 test Wells had pfass in them I mean
there just all the time and now all that
has to be treated in advanced ways so
these are expenses that we are paying
that I'm paying for my City's tip
tipping fees because the landfill has to
treat its Lee to this advanced level I
mean it's the cost keep going um if the
landfills leak then Heaven only help us
you know now um uh problem number three
three 3C chemical recycling spreads the
toxics and forms new toxics so here's
how it works the advanced recycling or
chemical recycling facility begins with
a mixture these eye popping containers
that probably are using some metals and
other interesting U maybe toxic
chemicals to make this such a bright
color fabric uh like this carpet that's
all plastic this material that came in a
in a in a um balance so that my husband
bought at Target um all these things are
going to get put into the hopper in a
chemical recycling facility and out
comes well during that during that re
reaction a lot of these chemicals get
collected but also new chemicals are
formed some of which we know as serious
toxins and 140 different ones by the way
um and some of which we don't even know
the names of yet because we haven't had
time to study all this then the products
from that are condensed into either of
two products into actually two products
Plastics and fuel in New Hampshire that
fuel can and be allowed to burned within
the facility that's our law for new for
advanced recycling allows that fuel from
this process to be burned within the
facility if you want to burn it
elsewhere and sell it and burn it
elsewhere then that's not called
Advanced recycling that's just called
paralysis and waste incineration both of
those processes are now allowed in New
Hampshire if you want to sell the
Plastics out of this then those Plastics
go on and become a desirable product and
here's a bottle that I found as waste as
a road trash in front of my house it
advertises 100% recycled
plastic that's a lovely concept however
if this recycled plastic is that
recycled plastic I don't think I want to
drink this
water because I don't know what will be
in it
it has come from all this other stuff I
don't know what it is furthermore that
plastic is turned into recycled plastic
toys so do I want my one-year-old
grandson do I want him to be chewing on
this I don't think so so we have we have
to stop and say these problems
associated with under
regulated weight
B cannot continue I know you can say
well this is expensive it's complicated
but this is too important to um just
wait for further decisions we can take
charge of this and that's where I want
to get to my
Solutions
so the solution the New Hampshire nhpr
can begin to limit the toxics there are
less toxic Solutions available for
example the um BPA was removed as soon
as we found out that it it impaired your
reproductive abilities and had some
cancer effects and so forth they came
out of the bottles and no bottle cost
anymore the manufacturers didn't have to
pay much for this because the chemists
could easily figure out a pathway to
produce these bottles without the BPA
that was just one problem so safer
packaging will create jobs here's an
fantastic opportunity from from for our
state we have so many waste wood feature
uh resources here because of our our
active um um Timber industry there's a
lot of waste wood we also have act
active agriculture that will have waste
agricultural natural materials all those
natural materials are
nontoxic
packaging this could be packaging
production Central for non-toxic
packaging and we just have to you know
continue to develop that industry it's
starting but we can develop it more here
our um nhbr is our next is our is the
next step you can open up to take um
we've already started with the the band
toxics in metals of 96 we can keep going
we can look at Main's epr they're smart
and granite Staters I think are just as
smart as the
Mayers so we can ban major persistent
toxics the be the past and heavy metals
we we can restrict health hazard
chemicals such as the phalates and the
BPA and so forth they have a very
concise way of phrasing it in the in the
law there we can they allow in the law a
very clever option here to either add or
remove substances from the banned or
regulated list so it stays updated and
this allows industry and scientists to
work together to solve the problems of
um um hazards in our in our life and
then it will can also limit the toxics
in recycling feed stocks so that this
material that has questionable
chemistry will not go into the recycling
pathway um and therefore what comes out
of the recycling pathway will then be
safer safe in safe
out so moving
on um the benefits um we let's just look
at in the past we took lead out of our
fuel we took lead out of our paint and
now the gas over that transition the
gasoline didn't cost more our cars still
and trucks still ran very well and our
now our paint and our homes is so much
safer and we don't have to pay in our
lives in our children's health um from
lead paint we can move on and um be safe
in our in our homes um another benefit
is this uh map here of the United States
showing you the wide spread you heard it
in the previous testimony the wide
spread of epr laws across the United
States many states have different kinds
of epr legislation and if we don't begin
on this then we will be behind in being
able to have our products sold in those
other states because we will have a
reputation that says don't buy from New
Hampshire you won't meet meet the other
State's regulations so all those
businesses are going to say sorry you're
New Hampshire you know we we'd rather do
business with a com with a state uh a
company in a state that has better laws
already on the books and we know what
they're doing we we can we can trust
what those other states are doing so the
industry benefits from no toxics and
packaging Forbes Magazine is a great
article about green certification boost
sales over competive s a huge amount so
when an industry says it's green it's
non-toxic it's sustainable um in its
practices they get more business not
less um hypertherm is a great example of
that um their policy to cut toxics at
all stages simplify their operations and
increase their sales um municipal waste
budgets we've heard a bit about this but
I can't underestimate how important this
is um less toxic Packaging means more
sales to recycling markets so that when
we have our transfer stations take the
carefully and um labeled and properly
arranged recycled materials aluminum
glass especially you know those easy to
easy identify ones perhaps some of the
Plastics when they identify those and
they know that they're non-toxic then
they can sell those to markets at higher
prices and those sales differences are
substantial so now that helps my town
budget and helps my taxes stay as low as
possible um we can save with the ReUse
of non-toxic and food service so when we
have a business that would otherwise
have waste materials in in takeout
materials instead if they shift to reuse
they would get a benefit from that that
would be part of not paying any
stewardship fees for having waste
materials but the bonuses that Simply
Having the reusable materials actually
saves them 2 to
$22,000 per year depending on how big
the restaurant is so the restaurant is
saving money twice once by not having to
buy the stuff in the first place second
not having to buy a potential
stewardship fee and then now they're
really in in good States so the
restaurants should like this um process
um now now we can move on to another
benefit confident companies every one of
the companies that I've shown you on
this picture are small companies it's
I'm not sure of the laws and the
regulations and the limits for for um
Commerce for and budgets in each one of
these these companies but they do way
way under a million dollars of business
under a 100,000 for some of them so
they're probably not going to be
impacted by the a number of bills
depending on how the the bill is
structured but here's the advantage that
they gain from having epr in New
Hampshire is the
reputation in a business reputation
means so much more and it really counts
for for their personal value but it also
counts on their their bottom line and so
having New Hampshire as an epr State
improves the reputation of all of these
companies because they sell online Way
Beyond New Hampshire
and also within New Hampshire these
other um other things is having an epr
Bill signals the packaging vendors that
each of these people has to call up and
say I need so much to put in my my bone
meal broth from I love Vernon Family
It's a Wonderful Farm um but when they
want to buy a bunch of packages they
can't negotiate with this company about
what's in your package what's in your
container they want to buy from somebody
that they know they can trust and when
they say oh I'm you're selling to New
Hampshire oh yeah we we got it covered
we sell to New Hampshire we sell to all
the epr states because we know what you
guys expect and we're going to give you
a good price so that's how they can make
their businesses more efficient um for
whether it's personal care products
t-shirts you name it you know they're
going to get a good deal um moving on um
confident consumers when we shop in New
Hampshire
and we're buying New Hampshire made
things New Hampshire packaged things we
will be confident whether we have a
little baby in the bin or whether we
have you know we're we're out there you
know shopping for ourselves um and also
when we're shopping online and remember
New Hampshire businesses do a lot of
online um um market and we want to be
able to advertise that market of safety
and reliability
online um so some special features in a
smart EP are these are almost near the
end here um it will have special
considerations for those small
businesses that I I just described a few
minutes ago they don't have a lot of
resources to verify the packaging
chemistry and sources to track the
packaging fate so I'm pretty sure that
the legislation will have considerations
for very small businesses so that they
don't have to um um you know bear a huge
burden of this but they can actually
generate from the advantages um of um
having this reputation as being a state
that's protective um they would reward
businesses by already using green
packaging that are least toxic reusable
natural materials easy to compost and
safe to recycle there are businesses um
such as some of those personal care
products I cited earlier and some of
those other Farms that I've cited those
people have already done their homework
they have already gone as sustainable as
you possibly can so they should get
reward rewarded for that they took it on
the chin to do it just because it's the
right thing to do now they can get a
financial reward for that or you know
generally benefit from it
overall so in conclusion um yeah in
conclusion I say first of all we are
paying extra for packaging we're paying
for too much packaging I now have to buy
one of my do green bags to put all this
stuff
in another bag another $10 you know each
week to put this stuff in something um
so already I'm paying too much for too
much packaging and in terms of my body
and my grandchildren's bodies we're
paying too much in toxics all right I
showed you that the statistics are
frightening um so epr is a way that we
can begin to solve these problems won't
do it all but we can begin it's a key
part of the healthy economies because it
will cut waste it will significantly cut
down roadside waste 70% roadside waste
reduction in in epr um States it will
cut the toxics in our lives and it will
save us then many costs for ourselves
and our
municipalities thank you for
listening and thank you for your very
informative
testimony are there questions yes please
Senator thank you Mr chair thank you so
much for that really
comprehensive um slideshow um my
question is I know that you have a deep
background in this um
realm knowing that there are six other
states who have
comprehensive um epr laws some of them
about to kick in of those states have
you taking a look at at any of
them they are there any that you know
because the states are wildly different
you know the E the economy of um and the
constituencies of California are you
know wildly different from New Hampshire
um but Maine our neighbor we have
roughly the same
population uh same climate same um
consumer
base there's also New Jersey who who do
you think is a good model for where New
Hampshire could look for guidance on
developing our
own EBR thank you so much for the
question um Senator I have only had time
to look at Mains so I will I have not
had a chance to do a cross check on the
others and I
would think that there is time in a um
if we were to develop legislation
uh there is time and there's more
expertise for fine-tuning the
legislation but if you look at the
Main's law I can actually I would I can
include I will update my slide to give
you the
exact
legislative number with too little you
know the exact legislative item in Maine
and you can read you can read it's 21:45
so got it up here I was wondering your
analysis of it yeah right and it seems
it seems very straightforward and it
seems like it has has been successful I
would have to you know I can't speak for
the Mayers but um that one is easy to
understand easy to read uh
practical I would start there um but I
would just start there but I again I
would say we have enough to
write practical legislation that's
appropriate for New
Hampshire we have enough now to to write
that
legislation thank
you other
questions
um I have
no we don't typically take questions
from the
floor
um
sorry yes if you'd like to
okay um but I do have a question
MH
um I'm more concerned about the
toxic components of some of these waste
that may may have previously been
concerned about Could you
um do you think an epr legislation would
effectively cause us both manufacturers
and consumers to take a harder look at
what we are putting on our landfills
knowing our past uh history of sometimes
overlooking these type of
things I think we have to be um I think
epr legislation and the charge of this
committee is focused on taking the
toxics out at the
start of the
process um and so you're dealing with
the water going into the bathtub your
keeping toxics out of water going into
the waste bathtub per se um in
epr and that will keep the drain of the
bathtub of waste you know from having
fewer toxics in it unfortunately the
landfills have Legacy toxics in them so
I would encourage you
to work on other legislation associated
with land fill toxics and so on
however
controlling what goes into recycling
feed
stocks is critical and limiting how you
define
recycling is critical in an
epr because if it's not carefully
designed and carefully limited and I
believe I don't know if I'm sure but I
think Maine has something about safe
recycling least toxic recycling
something about that because if you
don't
Define the nature of what you mean by
the word Recycling and recycled content
then we end up with this bottle coming
out
of this
mess if you don't Define it this is what
you're going to
get because this is the easiest path
who want who wouldn't want to just dump
this into a bin and have something that
looks like plastic smells like plastic
but is much more than just plastic um go
into this recycled
content and then we say we've done our
job we did not do our job because we
didn't take the toxics
out as feed stock for plastic
recycling does that help that does help
very much thank you so much thank you
further
questions I want to thank you for this
very uh I I got to say that I there are
points that I have not considered before
such as um alternative packaging being a
growth industry for New Hampshire these
These are exciting and potential ideas
thank
you
and finally I would like to hear from
Cindy
Heath
good morning good morning thank you
thank you representative partiall and uh
honorable members of the committee my
name is Cindy Heath and I live in
Cornish New Hampshire um I am the
convenor about three years ago of the
New Hampshire Network Plastics working
group and um the working group is a non
partisan all volunteer organization
founded in 2021 to help reduce plastic
waste and pollution in New
Hampshire I also volunteer at the
Cornish recycling center during the
winter months so I get to see firsthand
the waste management practices in my
town which is very
informative and my professional
background includes Community planning
and most recently providing technical
support to municipalities in the Upper
Valley who want to implement food scrap
diversion programs and I before I begin
I'd like to just build on something that
Cynthia um mentioned in her excellent
testimony and I have looked at the main
law epr law and and some of the other
companion laws not very recently but one
of the things that really impressed me
about Main's work in this area is that
they have a very extensive list of what
they call chemicals of
concern and given what was mentioning
about turning off the flow at the tap um
that is their entry into how to define
what types of chemicals can go into
packaging that is sold in Maine I don't
know if it's part of the epr law but I
know if you were to look um for
reference at chemicals of concern in
Maine you would see a very long list um
and that is a uh comprehensive way for
the state to Define what goes into the
packaging that's sold in
Maine so the Plastics working group
members are from 44 towns in every
region of the state and we have to date
implemented implemented more than 138
actions relating to policy citizens
engagement and systems change at the
local level these actions have directly
and indirectly impacted approximately
10,000 people in our state we work in
partnership with local and state
government businesses schools and
Community groups to achieve our goals of
reducing plastic waste and pollution in
New
Hampshire extended producer
responsibility legislation is very very
high on our list of solutions to this
growing
problem the history of epr goes back to
1990 actually beginning in Germany the
concept has been tested and researched
on a global scale for more than three
decades
in New Hampshire municipalities
businesses and consumers are already
doing their part some of the things that
are already going on in our state that
relate to this legislation are and this
solving this problem are that
municipalities are currently investing
heavily in recycling and its
infrastructure municipalities are imple
implementing pay as you throw
programs municipalities are piloting uh
trying to incorporate hard to recycle
items like textiles polystyrene also
known as styrofoam batteries and plastic
film into their
operations service clubs and
sustainability committees are hosting
Community swap events nonprofit
organizations are championing zero waste
campaigns entrepreneurs are opening
refill stations and zero waste grocery
stores restaurants and small businesses
are offering reusable and sustainable
Packaging
residents are practicing low and zero
waste shopping
efforts and finally Community groups are
incorporating zero waste principles into
event
management epr legislation simply
requires producers to participate in
expanding existing programs to increase
waste diversion and recycling thus
reducing Municipal tipping and
transportation fees and it also requires
businesses and producers to commit to to
ensuring the safe disposal of toxic
products and packaging that are
currently entering our municipal waste
streams the Plastics working group
supports a multifaceted approach to the
waste management challenges New
Hampshire is currently facing as noted
in Dr Walter's testimony epr legislation
with Appropriations to support the
Department of Environmental Services
oversight will address toxins leeching
into landfills and polluting our air and
water water as well as reduce the volume
of more than 1.5 million tons of waste
and I recently read something that it's
actually closer to 2
million um being processed by our New
Hampshire municipalities currently of
particular concern are the harmful
effects on children of the toxins and
food
packaging Clark uh in his earlier
testimony outlined the minimal impact on
consumers for the costs of products
included in epr legislation and earlier
testimony by P Christine babber of the
do plastics reduction group demonstrated
bipartisan support for the idea that
taxpayers shouldn't have to pay for the
cleanup of plastic waste created by
companies current Waste Management
Trends consider the disposal of products
that could be reused or recycled as a
waste of valuable resources as many
countries around the world and a growing
number of states have shown we can work
together with producers to implement
Fair epr legislation that incentivizes
the use of packaging and products that
are refillable reusable compostable and
recyclable sustainable packaging
alternatives are currently available and
widely in use by producers in Canada
Europe and the US so there is no need
for producers small or large to reinvent
the wheel when it comes to transitioning
to Safe biodegradable Packaging and
responsible product life cycle
management producers in these
jurisdictions are complying with the law
and research has shown that companies
can realize substantial cost savings by
transitioning to sustainable packaging
as long as recycling is convenient for
the consumer in the form of multiple
drop off locations Municipal recycling
rates have been shown to be as high as
75% and according to the research by the
recycling partnership recycl rates for
paper specifically show dramatic
increases with epr in several US states
and my written testimony has a couple of
um informative charts but I'll just
highlight one statistic from one of
these charts and you'll have that when I
uh give you the written
testimony in Colorado the recycling rate
went from
21% to 70% with epr legislation that's a
huge huge
increase the rec recycling partnership
also reports that the economic value of
recycled materials is significant for
the states in its study and again just
to site
Colorado the economic value of their
recycled material turned out to be $91
million Statewide a significant
significant
increase further eort efforts by The
Ellen MacArthur Foundation have resulted
in 11 leading Brands retailers and
packaging companies working towards
using 100% reusable recyclable or
compostable packaging by 2025 or sooner
amcore ecover Evan L'Oreal Mars M ands
Pepsi company the Coca-Cola Company unil
lver Walmart and wner and Mets these
companies together represent more than
six million tons of plastic packaging
per
year turning to New Hampshire the 2022
Department of Environmental Service
Services Solid Waste Management plan
cites epr legislation as a strategy to
address several goals in its 10-year
plan and my written testimony does have
the sightings of where these um items
are located in the solid waste
management plan but in the first goal um
the goal to reduce the quantity of solid
waste generated has the recommendation
to explore epr legislation and programs
the second goal to reduce the toxicity
of the solid waste stream has explor
legislation that would establish waste
disposal bands and epr item for items
such as rechargeable batteries
electronic devices paint and
Sharps and also exploring legislation
legislation to address the use of toxic
chemicals in products such as the use of
posos in carpeting clothing Upholstery
and food packaging so this is well
documented in our Solid Waste plan uh as
a recommendation and finally goal number
three is to maximize the diversion of
residential commercial and Industrial
solid waste from
disposal and so evaluating mandatory
recycling laws and epr programs is one
of the recommendations for legislation
in that goal so there's plenty of
support for the committee to move ahead
with um advancing this towards a
legislative review um in our existing
approved current Solid Waste Management
plan
um and finally um there's a
recommendation to explore product
stewardship and epr programs for a
number of other items including Plastics
and some of the other items that I
mentioned which are further described uh
in the written
testimony according to the product
stewardship Institute there are
approximately 100 epr policies across 33
States as of 2022 so we know that the
epr legislation is
Broad there's more than enough data for
policy makers to draw from to develop
legislation that works for us in New
Hampshire these policies focus on 15
different types of products including
products that are difficult to recycle
like Electronics paint carpet mattresses
fluorescent lighting product packaging
and
pharmaceuticals we know New Hampshire
can do better um we know that epr means
less waste and less toxins in our waste
stream
that reduces potential harm to Citizens
and the environment especially children
we know that epr can help save dollars
for our communities and I would just ask
you before I close to think about your
own recycling center or transfer station
in your town and how it might benefit
from extra funding to do things that it
cannot afford to do now and I know in
Cornish that is a significant challenge
for us we want to do better but
financially it's very difficult
in closing I urge the committee to use
the information that's readily available
from existing Global and state epr
experiences to recommend the submission
of epr legislation in this session We
Believe New Hampshire businesses
organizations government and individuals
are ready for this important step in our
state and can effectively work together
to protect the health of our citizens
and the environment we call home the New
Hampshire Plastics working group stands
ready to assist in any way the committee
believes would be beneficial
to advance your knowledge throughout the
legislative process thank
you and thank you for your testimony
questions thank you so much thank
you I'd like to see if anybody else
would like to come forward at this time
please fill little pink card at your
conven I don't need it right away but
make sure before we're conclude here
thank
you thank you so
much and usual introduce your so
so thank you I will be brief uh for the
record my name is jod grimus I'm a
lobbyist here in conquered and I work
with the American chemistry Council in
which there's a Plastics division um I
wasn't aware of kind of the focus
turning uh as it did today with a lot of
the testimony on the Plastics community
and I guess I would ask um I just
received a copy of a potential draft
piece of legislation that I think is
based on New York and Maine which there
have been concerns about from the
industry um I know I had spoken to the
chairman about potentially coming
forward and bringing someone in to talk
from an industry perspective um but we
had kind of thought it would be more
about advanced recy cing and then that
wasn't going to be part of it but I
would offer that I would like to have
that opportunity I don't know if you
have any more meetings in the future or
if it may be waiting till next
legislative session but I do think
um as as the prior speaker said there's
an opportunity for people to work
together here and industry has to be
part and at that table and I don't know
if that's the case and I think it should
be so I would make that offer I'm
certainly not the expert in those matter
matters but I would at least bring them
uh to this committee or to Future
committees because I think at some point
from what I understand in in Maine in
New York that hasn't been the case and
it hasn't necessarily worked well so I
will leave it at that and
I let let me know what you
think yes thank you for your brief
testimony um just a point of information
perhaps I think that all of us see that
this has to be a cooperative effort from
both industry the producers and the
consumers and this is our opportunity to
reset the unspoken rules that have
pretty much governed Us in the past when
it comes to our waste flow um however I
cannot see uh this being effective
without industry having a voice in it um
so I would expect that if and when our
committee decides that we would like to
continue this discussion I know there
are very many organizations
uh the N uh the
NR the municipal Organization for New
Hampshire number of organizations that
we have because of our limited time we
have not been able to call I would hope
that if legislation goes before the
committee we'll have the opportunity to
further dig into all of these issues
including the issues that you have great
so thank you thank
you further testimony
seeing on perhaps I can uh once again
Garner the thoughts of our
committee I'd like to thank everybody
who testified today I I think we got
some really good
information
uh
Mr Corson kind of convinced me in a in a
sense that um with his
testimony I'm my committee is
environment and Agriculture and I feel
that that maybe my committee should be
you know hear some of this
testimony but uh
overall I
think I I would like to see more time to
to see what happens in main I I would
like to I don't see the urgency I'd like
to see them let's see so that we know
know what happens with all parties I'm
concerned about that I I uh the advanced
recycling law Senate Bill
367 I believe has eased up the municipal
burden somewhat uh I'd like to see more
emphasis on on an awareness campaign for
both producers and
consumers and and I think with with that
information uh the market approach
rather than having this forced on on
companies uh let the free market
determine once they've been educated
people people may start use you know
using cardboard containers instead of
plastic or or bringing uh like the
chairman has a a container today rather
than than have buying a plastic bottle
uh you know that type of approach using
buying
biodegradable uh packaging you know
products that use that so so that's
that's kind of where I'm I am on
this and may I um ask our um respected
uh
representative do you feel that the
discussion and testimony will become
before Ena which is most likely where
any legislation would go I think that's
safe bet do you think that will happen
without us recommending further
legislation I don't know I've I've it's
come before us already
so I I think it will come back yes I
think it would come back I think it may
take some time to come back because I
know of no current legislation in the
hopper and the soonest would come back
would be
2024 however if we do recommend further
legislation and submit it to the OS
before November 7th we have the
opportunity to keep to uh ask for
further testimony in front of the uh
committee and at the end the ENA
committee may decide to not pursue this
they can always take um uh retain it uh
or whatever but I think that just having
that possibility opens up this issue to
keep it uh to keep all of our resources
on the
table yes please go
ahead thank you Mr chair so
um with all due respect my colleague I
um I think that history has shown us
that the free market approach to
handling Public Health has
been um wildly unsuccessful and I use in
this particular inset in um instance
BPA so
BPA
developed 12 years ago um was used in
baby bottles it was used to line uh cans
that have our vegetables in them and um
other products that we eat and um and it
is it is a very very dangerous toxin
that leeches out of those products and
into human bodies and
without
direction from
government we would still be feeding our
children BPA Laden bottles now you can't
buy a bottle in pretty much any store
without finding a a a a sticker or a
sign on it that says BPA free which lets
the consumer know that this particular
producer has taken the information that
BPA the the Plastics chemical BPA has
been removed from this particular
product
and it is um safe for human use so you
know this was the this was tighter
standards that was you know the
government had to put on producers
because it was much more um profitable
to do
nothing so um and once their product
goes out the
door no they they did not care whether
children were you know being exposed to
BPA whether we were being exposed to BPA
that was of no concern because once they
made the product went out the door got
sold to a you know to a supermarket and
there it's out of my hands out of my
hands I'm making money off of it so
um this is why this is why it's
important for us to with
seriousness understand the public Public
Health
dangers in doing nothing so in not being
proactive we ended up here in New
Hampshire with um a massive massive
amount of P contamination my community
in particular because we um have a
landfill in our community that was
unlined and no one thought like well you
know we're not required to do it no
body's making us do it it would probably
be a good idea but why it costs more
money now we have leech
everywhere subsequently you can't put in
a um landfill without lining it because
we made a government rule um so it has
long long been an
unfortunate um
byproduct of a free market is to
concentrate only on profit which great
that's what they do but uncontrolled
unregulated free markets um are not free
it's not free because who pays for it we
do so we're going to pay the medical
bills of the people who are exposed to
um bpas and all of the issues that come
along with that who's going to pay for
all of these massive Plastic Products
and the Mercury that went into
thermometers which the government had to
re in who's going to pay for the
electronics piling up who's going to pay
for all of these products that we are
consuming and
using we do we pay for them Coca-Cola is
not going to pay for
them PNG is not going to pay for them
we're going to pay for for them um so
all this extended product producer
responsibility concept does is
bring everybody into the same space
of shared responsibility so yes we have
a responsibility to purchase products
that do less
harm however if there aren't enough of
them out there
we don't have a lot of choice how free
is that not very so we have
already Canada has um has been operating
their extended producer
responsibility um laws since the
1990s they have a population of
38.25 million people so that's the
equivalent of 29 New
Hampshire um so since the 199 90s
they're way ahead of us on this
California New Jersey Washington
Colorado Maine all of these states have
also enacted extended producer
responsibilities because they understand
that it is a shared responsibility
between the consumers the consumers
communities our municipalities and the
producers who are bringing products into
our
municipalities um that are not 100%
usable there there is packaging and we
have to deal with that the total of all
those States is 63.3 4 million Consumers
Plus the
38.25 million consumers so just in the
United States we have the um a consumer
population the equivalent of 45 New
Hampshire
so um and then most of these most of
these laws also also take into account
the European article numbers which EUR
Europe is also far ahead of us on this
so product uh producers understand this
is coming and they would
love to not have to do it now because it
costs a little more it costs more money
you know it just it costs more money I
would love to not have to pay the
$250 then it's going to cost to clean
out my chimney um because you know it's
it's expensive and I have a car payment
and my car is actually doing some funky
things so it has to be dropped off this
week so $250 is like I really don't want
to have to spend that money but I know
that if I don't spend that money then I
am going to have a potential hazard in
my
house and I haven't taken care of of it
so by not participating in extended
producer responsibilities we're
just postponing the hazard and we all
know when you work with a municipal
project and you put off doing the
municipal project it never gets less
expensive absolutely not never gets less
expensive so we have an opportunity
right now to participate with the
producers to find a space that works the
best for us here in New Hampshire and we
we are not making it up other there's so
many other states countries that have
already done this and have data for us
already
so I think we can we can all agree that
we have some very toxic chemicals
already floating around in our
watersheds um and we have you know shut
down some things that had been putting
air pollution into our communities and
before this gets more out of hand we
need to make a good faith effort at
joining with producers to figure out how
they can be responsible for what they're
coming in and how we can join them in
that
responsibility so um I would propose
that we particularly take a look at um
the New
Jersey
proposal um I think there's a lot of
aspects of the New Jersey epr that would
um that we could we could actually pluck
out that would be appr appropriate for
New Hampshire and also look at so main
one of the things they did was put
together um what are they calling it a
um sustainability office and the
sustainability office um from from the
the read I have of it from the
legislation operates very similarly to
our
EFA office so it's a contract so the um
sustainability office um gets is a a
contracted vendor if you will from um
the Department of Environmental Services
and the money to sustain that comes from
some of the
um responsibility money from the
producers that coming in and that helps
to manage the
program so that's just a tiny overview I
know there are a lot more details than
that but I do think that there are some
models that we we would be it would be a
great great benefit to New Hampshire to
look at these before um it costs us even
more money with pollution
mitigation because that I promise you is
more
expensive
thank
you my thoughts on this are that I would
like to see this issue stay alive I did
I did share with you a
draft piece of epr
legislation
and I do not see that as a final answer
but I do see is something that would
come before the ENA committee to keep
the conversation alive to keep us
I feel like I've had a tremendous
education over the last three weeks here
and I would like that opportunity to go
before the ENA committee as well so
I um I would really hate to think that
the report that I've been uh
commissioned to draft would be the final
word for a couple years I would much
prefer it seeing it as one step forward
that
includes uh recommended
legislation uh that I can't imagine
would would I I I have to image would be
seriously uh amended but at the end
something which we would
all be able to equally like or dislike
something for everybody um that's not
going to happen if we bury this right
now in a report so I strongly Advocate
moving forward submitting legislation to
OSS and getting this before the ENA
committee so that we do not have to wait
another year to attack our waste flow
problem um I will also add I don't know
if you've noticed in the uh legislation
that I uh drafted that um there's no
mention of advanced recycling there's no
mention of bottle bills there's a
mention of toxic substances all of these
would have to be negotiated and all
these would have to
be uh considered with more mins than
just my own if we're going to going to
have something that works for everybody
uh I strongly recommend uh um and we do
have a a quorum here today and I think
we need to be appropriate to take a vote
on whether or not we do want to submit
legislation to ol in this matter
um so as I am serving as clerk as oh
please go
ahead ask a question yes thank you Mr
chair so um are you are you making a
motion to to adopt this language with
opportunity for rewrite or as is like is
there an once it's
submitted are you submitting as is or
with opening that 10day space
for for editing if there's other
information can I just say
yes I'm I I am open to either um I
really think that either way is not
really significant because this is more
of a door stop or a bookmark than it is
an actual finished product um so I would
be more than open to either frontloading
it before it goes to L us if comments
are to be made or submitting it and
letting uh it come before Ena and then
the Senate and having it decided there I
I could go either
direction um and I would welcome your
thoughts on
that um I I was told earlier in this
committee that that this was
formed this committee was to look at uh
saving the burden to in and saving money
to the towns by reducing uh the amount
of of waste that goes into the
landfills uh and I I've heard so much
more than that today about what toxicity
at I mean that I really honestly wasn't
aware of some of the stuff I heard today
but uh I think we're getting off a
little bit from what the topic was
originally
and
uh that's where I'm at with
that should I add that my original input
on what this bill was to um because my
own landfill or transfer station was was
self- sustaining and being able to
recycle the plastic was coming into it
until the plastic Market collapsed and
now they're talking about significant
increases in my own Hometown so reducing
Municipal costs is very dear to me and I
think that is addressed somewhat in the
draft legislation as well um the
testimony that I've heard
today
is only increases
my ear urgency to see something passed
not just for the uh Financial aspects of
it but for the environmental aspects of
it um does that answer
please thank you Mr chair um and I'm
happy to provide a little clarification
um because our in our um in our charge
our study extended producer
responsibility as a mechanism for
meeting the waste reduction goals
established in RSA 149 m so um when we
look at the waste reduction goals of 149
M um one of those original goals was to
divert at least 40% of solid waste from
disposal by the year 2000 and
unfortunately um we don't have we have
not met that um one of the other goals
in RSA 149 m is number one source
reduction reduced a generation of waste
diversion
recover discarded resources and avoid
disposal and then disposal landfill or
incinerate items that can't be reduced
or diverted
so the you know
um in fact there is a chart of on 149 M
which is an
inverted pyramid that shows this is the
most preferred method and the most
preferred method here is source
reduction so which is what we're talking
about here and the least preferred
methods to meet the goals of 149 M are
landfills
incineration uh and waste to energy
those are you know in that order um with
the least of course being landfills
because now we have heard today that
unchecked landfills and overburdened
landfills particularly when we don't
even know what's coming in from out
other states um gives us a lot of toxics
that we end up having to deal with again
that costs us a lot of money so um
Source reduction Recycling and reuse and
composting is right in the center but
the most preferred for RSA 149 M was
Source reduction which what is our
charge um with this committee is to
figure out how to do some Source
reduction um
so um you know this this program that
highlights and breaks down RSA 149
M um you know underlines that's that's
what we're that's what we're here to do
and we have other bills that are still I
know one of them stuck in finance right
now but we do have some other groups
within the legislature who are working
on a addressing the prospects of
chemical recycling um which is its own
we got a little taste of it today of
um
from uh Cynthia who you know just gave
us a little insight into it but that's
that's well beyond the scope of this
committee and there's actually other
committees who are working on that right
now like this not this moment but in
this session um so you
know if we stick to our
charge and go straight from the statute
and T possible targets for epr include
packaging single-use Plastics beverage
containers electronic waste batteries
automotive waste and hazardous waste and
use those if or a couple of those to
input into possibly this proposed
legislation from representative parcel
that um we have a we we have a
solid F to stand on and bringing
something forward and we have met the
objectives I think um given the very
limited scope of House Bill
253 um because we have you know met all
of the other criteria
so we're we're down to number five of
hb250
three I could return this one moment
um I think that more eyes you asked me a
question earlier what I want to see
further drafts before it's SP to ol or
after I almost think that at this point
maybe further eyes on it and further
testimony May well hopefully will make
it a stronger piece of legislation uh
um I would like to that's try to get a
straw poll here I think I know how you
feel do you feel like may be appropriate
at this time to submit further
legislation to keep it in front of the
committee
process okay and how may I ask be very
Frank how do you think it will come up
you said something in
finance I think that was Advanced
recycling though that was in finance no
I'm sorry if there was some confusion in
my um explanation this is the only space
where we're really dealing with the um
Extended producer responsibility some of
the other topics that have come up that
are out of the scope but that have come
up here um are being addressed in other
committees so my my statement was that
some of those things that are out of our
scope are being addressed but within our
scope there is nothing right now which
is why we're here um
so you know we we have
to s in fact we are charged with
suggesting possible legislation and or
rules for implementing approaches that
would be readily adaptable to New
Hampshire and may propose topics for
even further study so we are charged in
our statute to suggest possible
legislation that is that's just what
that's what was signed by the governor
so um to meet the go to to meet Our
obligation uh we have we have
done Parts
one we have almost finished part two we
have done
Parts three four and we are not done
with
five so
so um it I don't know that it's an
option not to bring something forward
because it was not put as an
option so we have to suggest
something which is why I asked if
representative parcel would be open to
any changes to what he has proposed
because I don't I didn't bring a
proposal for today um but I would like
to participate in
any of the redraft because you know what
comes forward out of this committee is
our work
so would you support it with a
redraft I I guess I would like to see
education to the consumer things like
that I at least put you know I'd like to
have my
concerns
yeah I I think the draft was was kind of
one-sided I I know uh representative
bruad had called me and he has the same
concerns that I do I I can't speak for
him but
um oh
yeah like the Senate has said I I don't
know maybe we have to put something
forward here but I just want my concerns
noted in your report I guess I certainly
think it's appropriate to have all the
concerns noted in the report and I would
not think other I mean I hope you know
that I would not consider otherwise
however I going back to uh five
um I'm also really feeling
that we
have a a bill
that passed the house and consent passed
the Senate and consent and I see both
these as a real hunger to learn more
when it comes to education to learn more
on the behalf of both of on of on the
behalf of the
legislature um I think consumers have
had quite a bit of time to educate
themselves and I think if you look right
now there's even an effort well I've
seen Delta Airlines a lot lately and how
they're going to be carbon n by 2050 um
I think there's real effort in education
consumers from the standpoint of
Industry um I think it's the legislators
that might benefit from further
education which is why I would love to
see something go forward and maybe could
I ask could we work together because I
did not see this as one-sided of course
but it is my perspective I don't deny
that could we work together in order to
come up something to uh satisfy our
fifth requirement would you feel uh
I believe so
yes yeah so while we're you know while
we're digging into this where um because
we can do some of this work right now
where are the spaces uh within the
propos within the proposal that are that
are giving you our bur so that we can
like you know maybe maybe we can talk
through some of these right now um to be
perfectly honest representative partial
I'm not I'm I am not able to see an
education like a consumer education
component is that we're talking about
yeah so
is I have not um I controlled off my way
through this and can't find it so is
that something you would be open to
adding because it looks like from the
um packaging reduction organization
which sounds very similar to the way
Maine came forward that um I know in
Maine an education piece for consumers
is part of their
process um that is some of the charge of
their what are they calling it hold on a
second
okay Vermont calls theirs the
Stewardship
Council but very much the same it's just
you know whoever the separate entity
is so yeah are there's what are the
specific spots that maybe we can um dig
into
I just I'm I know in this room there's
an urgency for this I'd like to see how
it plays out in Maine for all parties I
I don't see the urgency in it um I think
with with education we live in a a free
market Society I think that I I really
believe that if if people were educated
instead of uh getting a plastic bottle
of water you'd bring a container from
home I think you'd buy the cardboard
package container instead of the plastic
I I think you might buy something that's
packaged biodegradable let the let the
market determine that I I believe
that'll if people were educated I
believe that would would help I I just
don't think it should be forced on
producers and let's let's find out what
Maine's doing Maine would be the closest
one to us I I I don't think New
Hampshire and New Jersey are would would
be a Fair Fit I don't think California
certainly wouldn't be I think Maine
would uh I think Maine is a close to New
New Hampshire I that's what I'd like to
see is is let it play out a little bit
and see how it affects all
parties um okay I I'm sorry Mr chair may
I respond thank you um thank you thank
you very much
um I do want to bring back into this uh
this discussion that
we that our free market economy is not
entirely free in fact we have a
significant number of regulations about
how certain products um can be made and
sold we for instance you know measure um
how how much um non-flammable material
goes into products that go on our
children and when we had you know
recognized that these
non-flammable components of children's
pajamas were actually poisoning them um
we as the government stepped in and said
no we're not going to do that anymore
you're going to have to take that out
same thing with BPA you're going to have
to take that out when um you know when
cigarettes even used to be unfiltered
and before we really wrapped our brains
around the fact that you know smoking is
something that actually kills you we you
know put filters on you know we have
done incremental things to make our
communities our citizens and our
um and our environment safer we have
rules and regulations about how much
toxin you can spew in the air that's why
we have a Environmental Services
protection commission you know we it's
not a free-for-all it's a it it is a you
know monitored space um and so you know
which is why we have health regulations
for restaurants um we don't let the free
market rule our public health and when
we do it we end up suffering which is
how um you know which is how we came
across the fact that pasas has been
poisoning people all across my community
the maram community I know you have a
colleague in the house who has um pasas
related cancer uh so it it's there it's
happening we have to deal with it
and so it's not a free-for-all we we get
to make some we get to put the bumpers
on this Lane and the question is what
are the bumpers look like there can't be
no bumpers because without any bumpers
then we're just paying for it in our
Municipal tax bills we're paying for it
at the state level so we're going to pay
for it all of it so we want to share the
cost that's it seems you know the longer
we wait the more we pay and I quite
frankly I don't I don't want to keep
paying for somebody else's you know
laziness or you know profit
margins because we're not asking them to
do what they are asked to do in other
states and in Canada like they're
already making these products for other
people but we don't get them because
we're not asking for them so this is
this is where I want to just make sure
that we're all on the same page about
there being bumpers on the free market
you know I I understand that totally and
in the things you're talking about are
the products themselves and the safety
of the products this and and we're
Commissioned I believe for the packaging
to make less of it go into the landfills
not not to make the products themselves
safer am I am I wrong in saying that the
pro the packaging is the
product that is all part of the product
about flammable uh clothing for children
and that's not the packaging that's the
product that's
s okay
um my apologies for not having a more
specific um my my intention on using
that as an example is to demonstrate
that we have government spaces where we
can we can in say to producers of
products and packaging is a product um
that you can't put this kind of
chemicals into these products so a
better example if we want to be if we
want to stay uh with Fidelity to the
pack to the issue at hand is BPA inside
of cans where you get your corn beans
green beans garbanzo beans soup where we
were buying baby bottles and baby
bottles you don't you know it's a rare
occasion to buy one they come in big
packs and those were Laden with BPA
until we stepped in and said nope so now
what we're talking about is all of the
plastic and all of the packaging that
goes on those improved products you know
we're talking
about big jugs
of uh laundry detergent we're talking
about um metals that come in our
Electronics we're talking about paint
we're talking about all kinds of things
so recognizing that the
packaging is part of the
product so we uh are speaking if we do
submit and I'm just going to go ahead
with this you know assumption for the
moment here we need to have something
more about education within this
bill would that make it more of a Savory
situation yeah okay um how do we get
that in there do we work together you
and I the three of us or would you like
me to just take that on I think Maine
has something like this we could model
it somewhat after Maine yeah I I think
that you have some strong feelings about
how what it would look like for the
education component um and who pays for
that like you know is it is it something
that the
manufacturers you know pay into a state
fund is it something that is part of
their own marketing campaigns there's
all ways of figuring does the state take
this on like who does the education what
does it look like um and you know would
you be open to you know figuring that
piece of this out while during the
redraft I'd rather leave it in your
hands I'm happy to either and I would
like to submit it to if your approval
though and we should at least have some
discussion on it I want to make sure
that it meets your you know uh like to
try to be fair of course we're all have
our own perspective you know can I point
out one other thing I think is might be
somewhat relevant I don't have the
feeling right now that we really are
dictating to the industry to the
producers in so far as many of The
Producers just about all the producers
we have heard from have endorsed the
idea of at least beginning the process
of EPA legislation
I think they're doing that because they
see it as a it's on the horizon for them
already with so many other places
and they realize that it's just a matter
of time here and they would love to have
a seat at the table so they are
endorsing this and I think that's a very
positive thing to have them on board
with it and I would sincerely like to
take advantage of that and the other
thing which really strikes me off very
heavily is that when it comes to paper
and what color and we know what color AO
dead they increase their recycling rates
to for 23 to
70% I think that's an amazing uh and I'm
sure they did that with some
education um but it
also
gave the consumers something to work
with just like this legislation here I
know it's been difficult for the people
that come and testified because we don't
have any legislation in front of them
and they're used to having legislation
in front of them this is study committee
but if we get legislation in front of
them we can have these different groups
come in and say we like this we don't
like that and it'll be it will encourage
a deeper discussion than I think what we
W able to have here and also more
relevant to a broader number of people
who already support the concept of vpa
VPR um so that's my thoughts right there
um may I go ahead and uh start drafting
education and what else are there other
areas or areas we might want to remove I
I'm also open to that I think that
anything we do may be further amended
down the line so I'm very open to the
whatever we need to this to get this on
to the next
step Mr chair please thank you um with
regards to what we heard from Miss
grimas um there is actually
documentation from the American
chemistry Council um on their working
with California and they have outlined
the objections that they had in the
process so we have you know we we have a
document here that says this is where
we're struggling you know so I mean that
information is not unknown so we we are
we do have that so that's you know one
thing we can factor
into our document because we know where
some of the producers are coming from um
and where they're struggling with so we
want to be able to be
cooperative
um with all
partners and I also know you've been
taking very copious notes today and if
you'd like again to draft them into
uh very often these reports also have a
Minority Report element to them and I
would certainly welcome that or if you
want to incorporate it in the regular uh
report I'm happy either way on that
whatever you would like to go
that but I but I really do think it's
important we hear all these voices and
we continue to hear them so what I'm
gathering right now and correct me
please if I'm wrong um and I hope I'm
not uh if we are able to redraft this
legislation this proposed legislation
that OLS has not even seen yet um but if
we're able to redraft that to something
that does include something about
education and perhaps some other issues
then we can go ahead and submit this and
knowing that it will probably be even
further amended by Ena or whatever
committee it's assigned to are we pretty
much in consensus on that do you feel
yeah and would you mind if I if I could
email you just a like a small Report
with my concerns
and add that into it more than mine I'd
be very grateful for that
okay well I'll I move that we
accept
um did you put a number on it okay
accept the proposed legislation that
came out of this summer committee um an
act to require companies selling
offering for sale or Distributing
products contained in packaging to
minimize consumer packaging by
prescribed goals set by the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services accept as written
pending with opportunities for this
committee to add changes um that this go
forward to the speaker for exception for
assignment into the LSR list
I think I worded that
appropriately we have a
second yes great uh all all in favor I
I okay great okay uh I think that
concludes our business not only for
today but for not the foreseeable future
because we all need to be in touch as
far as getting this um redrafted before
we even submit it to law less but my by
the end of oh please do please do um so
that sounds great perfect and thank you
very much and once again thank you to
all those that testified and also sat
through the
testimony oh motion to adjourn we don't
need that do we all in favor stand
up